على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية ، سعت دبي
إلى وضع نفسها كمركز اختبار للتكنولوجيا المتقدمة
المبتكرة
من المركبات ذاتية القيادة إلى
إنشاء أول معمل ذكاء اصطناعي في المنطقة
يوفر للمبتكرين والباحثين
قدرات حوسبة عالية الأداء
مبادرة blockchain على مستوى المدينة
لصندوق استثمار بقيمة 270 مليون دولار
في الشركات الناشئة في مجال
التكنولوجيا وحتى رجال الشرطة الآليين ، تعد دبي
هي المكان الأكثر مستقبلية على هذا
الكوكب ،
حيث يتم تجربة كل شيء مستقبلي في دبي بما
في ذلك بالطبع سيارات الأجرة الطائرة والروبوتات في
المركز التجاري
وفقًا لسعر عمال البناء
خلال العقد
القادم ومن المتوقع أن يساهم الذكاء الاصطناعي في أكثر من  15
تريليون دولار للاقتصاد العالمي
و 96 مليار دولار في الإمارات وحدها
بين عامي 2015 و 2018 تقول دبي إنها
احتلت المرتبة الأولى عالميًا
في جذب أكثر من 21 مليار دولار في
الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر
عندما افتتحت دبي اقتصادها بعد
الإغلاق المنشود
في الحدث الأول الذي عقد في  كانت المدينة هي
الباركود السنوي لكل شيء في المؤتمر
تدعو الورقة المستبدلة إلى إجراء فحوصات درجة الحرارة والتباعد الاجتماعي وفقًا للمعايير الجديدة ، لكن الرسالة كانت هي أن دبي تظل ملتزمة بالابتكار في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي ، أنا هنا اليوم للإعلان عن بعض المبادرات التي نعمل على تنفيذها في مبادرات من شأنها تحسين نوعية الحياة جعل الذكاء الاصطناعي متاحًا للجميع ، ولكن ليس فقط المبادرات الحكومية هي التي تقود الطريق التي أسست بها أنجليكا إكشتاين شركة AI الاتجاهات في عام 2017 على أمل الاستفادة من دعم دبي المتزايد لخدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل رواد الأعمال التقنيين الآخرين في المدينة عندما تفشى جائحة فيروس كورونا لقد أدارت نشاطها التجاري ، لذا فإن ما تراه هنا هو كيف نقيس المسافة بين الأشخاص ، لذا فإن التطورين اللذين قمنا بهما من أجل covid19 هما عين الأمان حتى نتمكن من تحديد ما إذا كان الناس لديهم درجة حرارة على سبيل المثال ويمكننا اكتشاف ما إذا كان الناس يرتدون أقنعة الوجه الأخرى تسمى العين على المسافة والفكرة هنا هي فهم ما إذا كان الناس  حافظ على المسافة
الاجتماعية ، يمكن استخدام البرنامج في أي كاميرا
أو مع أي
بيانات تدفق فيديو يمكن لصانعي القرار
استخدامها لتنفيذ قيود التباعد الاجتماعي
طالما لدينا موجز فيديو في
معيار الصناعة المشترك ،
يمكننا فقط التخطيط له من
البرامج الحكومية إلى البرامج الخاصة  الشركات في
دبي أصبحت بسرعة
مركزًا تقنيًا محددًا للصناعة
حيث قاد كوفيت 19 الإمارات
والشركات إلى إعادة التفكير في
حلول الذكاء الاصطناعي وإعادة تنظيمها
لتسريع التحول الرقمي
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة